let's talk about the drop in crypto and
is it good for for companies ripple and
ftx are now going all in on acquisition
targets because they are flush with
capital and asset prices valuations
multiples etc have declined over the
last six to 12 months now so crypto
companies raised a record 30 billion
dollars of venture capital last year
more than 1800 deals took place last
year and the investment in crypto was 7
of all venture capital investment
globally and mergers and acquisitions
were up more than 55 billion in 2021 in
the crypto space that's from just 1.1
billion in 2020. it's almost a 50x in
the mergers and acquisitions in that
space and now what we've seen is
companies like ftx companies like ripple
companies like uh others in the crypto
space have cash right not only have they
raised money but some of these companies
are profitable and have a large amount
of cash on their balance sheet or
equivalent securities and now they have
the opportunity to see some of these
businesses that they may be like before
can be added to them or be good from a
synergy perspective and they can go
acquire some of these at a cheaper rate
because the market has pulled back
valuations have compressed multiples
have compressed et cetera so what i
think we're going to see over the next
few months is cash is king and i think a
lot of companies that knew this the
greatest operators that are out there
saw that a crash was coming in the
economy saw that a recession might be on
the horizon here in the united states
and acquired as much cast as humanly
possible because they knew that a time
like this they could go hunting it's
clearance sale they can literally go out
and pick companies that may not be able
to afford to stay alive right if you're
a company that's venture-backed and
you've raised money you can either do a
down round you can try to go find more
capital some other way you can try to be
become profitable very quickly you can
get acquired you can do something else
but ultimately your one job is to not
run out of money so the companies that
have cash right now whether you're a
venture capitalist or whether you're a
company like ftx or others that have a
large amount of cash on their balance
sheet they're playing offense why
everyone else is playing defense and i
think that's a big distinguishing factor
of what we're going to see in the crypto
space over the next six months 12 months
18 months whatever however long it lasts
of this bear market where people just go
out and the ones with cash are playing
offense the other ones are playing
defense and a lot of those companies
will probably end up either shutting
down or getting acquired and that's just
a fact yeah across the board though
every industry this is where big players
are made right when everyone else is
struggling can you go
can you go acquire companies can you go
build your business and make your
business even stronger from the core and
that's where you get the multiples are
down so you can get better valuations
for companies when you actually acquire
them
but yeah ftx and ripple they're doing a
great job of this i think they're going
to be the winners if they can acquire
good companies at a cheap price um and
bring them into either their product
shut them down take over their employees
like anything they can do to kind of
merge the two companies and acquire
other companies in this downturn and
still be profitable in the end is going
to be the key here but it's across the
board i think when recession hits
companies valuations draw down and the
stronger companies go on almost an
acquisition spree very smartly though
and very uh with well risk management
because you don't want to overextend
yourself and then you're caught where
the company was that you acquired well
the truth is too that we haven't had a
major recessionary period really since
2008 or 2001 right so a lot of people
that are operating these businesses
today uh maybe weren't running companies
back then or just founded companies
right if you think about someone who's
20 to 30 years old like they didn't see
that recessionary period so in my
opinion at least like there's probably
going to be a decent amount of carnage
just from people who aren't prepared or
do not know how to transition their
business quick enough
because ultimately the venture capital
dries up we've already seen this venture
capitalists are talking about this every
single day now of like their inability
to go fund a bunch of deals because
they're slowing down investment growth
is slowing down they're unwilling to
attack some of the valuations that they
saw previously and invest at those
levels because they were unreasonable
then and they're even more unreasonable
now so i think what we're going to see
is the ones that are going to survive
this are the ones who have already cut
back spending they're already the ones
that are focusing on profitability
they're already the ones that have
extended their run rate and lowered
their burn rate they're the companies
that are out there uh proactively doing
a lot of these things working with the
venture capitalists and the investors on
their cap table to make sure that they
survive and i think the companies that
ftx and others with cash on their
balance people target are the ones who
are not doing that correctly right who
are running out of cash who need a
lifeline want to make some money wants
to turn a profit for investors et cetera
and i think ftx is in a good position to
do that yeah that was a blueprint for
founders you just laid out oh yeah i
mean i'd listen to a lot of other smart
people so that helps yeah i like that
yeah reduce burn rate
that's true reducing burn rate uh i mean
look at spending the the the game right
is just don't run out of money it's
literally the only the like the golden
rule where do companies do you think
they focus on reducing burn rate though
is it employees they just cut employees
that aren't needed do they cut marketing
for sales right like those things are
directly tied to revenue a lot of the
time well i think in a lot of cases uh
what's the saying it's like a good
company has uh has uh a good company has
three times too many employees a great
company has two times too many right and
the whole idea is right once you get
bigger you get bloated you start hiring
for different roles that you probably
don't need or other people can do you
get excess you know kind of fat around
the company and in some cases sure it
sounds kind of evil to say but like you
can cut some of that off you can trim
some of that right so maybe that's one
part of not hiring or hiring freezes
versus firing even so there's multiple
different ways to look at it from that
avenue but i think we've also seen this
in the advertising space right we've
already seen it and we will continue to
see this where companies are cutting
back that spend because that's what you
look to first where is money leaving the
business right hiring and uh and
employees are certainly one marketing
spend is another sponsorships all that
stuff are
high spend categories for some of these
companies especially in the crypto space
over the last few years so you start to
cut back on that as quickly as you can
and all you're really trying to do is
extend your run rate extend and lower
your burn extend your run rate so then
what you can do is you can lengthen the
the survival rate of your company so you
don't have to bring in excess money or
maybe you raise money right before
because raising right now it's difficult
a lot of companies you see in the news
are taking down rounds uh they're
they're giving more preferential
treatment to venture capitalists whether
it's uh things like board seats or other
things like that right just things that
they might not have done a month ago or
three months ago or six months ago
because where the market was at so when
that changes the the the factors around
these valuations and the factors around
these deals have to change also yeah
you're seeing companies not only not
raise rounds but raise them at the last
valuation that was six months ago right
when they were doing a lot better um and
they're doing that for a very specific
reason because they need the cash so
they're either lowering their equity
amount they're taking dilution and just
saying hey we need the cash i want this
company to survive or they're literally
going hey you guys can put more money in
at the last valuation even though even
though our revenue is up more customers
whatever it may be it's you guys can
have that opportunity because you
believe in us and you also have the
capital that we need hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time